Can I bring my friend?
I have no idea where your clothes are.
This foreigner says that
he can't find his clothes.
-Do you know anything about it?
-No.
All I did, was ask if I can
bring a friend along.
But they seem to be flustered.
Are they worried because they don't
want us to copy their style of bathhouses?
This sure is a problem.
I just replaced my husband at this post,
so I have no idea.
My husband went to play the slot machines.
It's too bad…
I understand that these flat-faced people
cherish their bathing culture.
But now that they're
part of the Roman Empire,
they must understand that the Romans
have the right to take in their culture.